cabe decir que el hermetismo atraviesa
la información que proviene desde
Nicaragua lo que hemos podido recabar en
las últimas horas justamente con medios
locales agencias internacionales que
citan a Fuentes diplomáticas Y eclesias
eclesiales es que sí hubo una
excarcelación de monseñor Rolando
Álvarez pero que las negociaciones para
sacarlo del país entre la conferencia
episcopal de Nicaragua los enviados del
Vaticano y el régimen de Ortega
fracasaron de manera que habría sido
devuelto a la cárcel la modelo Donde ha
estado retenido durante varios meses
Pero mientras se conocía esta
información el cardenal Leopoldo brenes
que es el arzobispo de Managua refutó
desmintió lo dicho por estas Fuentes
aludiendo a que en ningún momento el
obispo Rolando Álvarez ha salido de la
cárcel calificó de especulaciones esta
noticia estas noticias de la
excarcelación Aunque cabe decir que
Álvarez si han visto la cara en todos
estos meses pero las fuentes
eclesiastres
eclesiales y diplomáticas insisten en
que durante las pocas horas de la
excarcelación pues Rolando Álvarez
habría estado resguardado en la
conferencia
episcopal solo solo que él no quiso irse
Porque la única manera de que él salga
de Nicaragua es que o se lo ordene el
papa o se lo pida el propio Papa
Francisco Andrés vamos a hablar ahora un
poco del contexto de esta noticia
contanos Quién es Álvarez Y por qué se
encuentra en prisión
bueno monseñor Rolando Álvarez tiene 56
años él representa el único Obispo en
haber sido arrestado durante el régimen
de Ortega es el mayor prelado de la
Iglesia Católica en estar arrestado se
convirtió en un Severo crítico de Daniel
Ortega después de la represión de las
protestas antigobierno 2018 donde
murieron más de 300 personas él solía
tanto en la Eucaristía como en las redes
sociales hablar en contra del régimen de
una pues manera sutil hablaba mucho de
las diferencias entre el cielo y el
infierno entre Dios y el enemigo al que
hay que vencer y eran sus propios
seguidores los fieles de la Iglesia
Católica que acudían a sus iglesias
quien a su a sus misas quienes
reconocían que el cielo era la libertad
y el infierno era el régimen de Daniel
Ortega entonces para esa época Ortega
dijo que
los obispos en Nicaragua eran
terroristas y incitaban al odio Así que
en febrero de este año Pues él fue
condenado a 26 años de prisión luego de
que no quisiera irse como desterrado en
el grupo de los 222 que fueron exiliados
por el régimen de Daniel Ortega